[Music]
what do you mean we're lucky to be white
it's not luck it's privilege we're
privileged that people see us not a
color privilege that we don't get stared
at when we walk into the room privilege
that we don't get followed by security
when we go shopping or pulled over when
we're in the wrong neighborhood we're
privileged because Society was set up
for us and our silence keeps it in place
we're privileged and that's
unfair oh gosh darn it that ended a
little bit early I was about to write
white on my
forehead but here we are uh that video
was making the rounds on the Twitter
yesterday my friend James Lindsay found
it and it's just one of those generic
guilty white people look at us we're so
awful we scribble things and we're
privileged
and and I felt I had to show it to you
why I don't know I'm Dave ruin this is
the Ruben report it's January 9th 2024
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals postgame show Ruben report.
locals.com if you want to query me
comment or correct any of the various
errors I might make over the next 45
minutes or so uh and the theme of
today's show as we've been getting some
wins against the woke is uh a little bit
of a time machine today we're going to
go back in time and look at some of the
ways the woke have been lying to us
destroying our institutions uh wrecking
Havoc Across America and all over the
world and that the elites are a little
scared at the moment and that actually
is good because no one wants to live in
their collectivist uh hypocritical
ridiculous woke world uh this will
include Clips by comedians Jame Gaffigan
and Ricky Jer and a whole bunch of other
Hollywood wackadoodles should we just
dive right into it let's dive right into
the show uh the Golden Globes you know
about these things Hollywood there's
nothing that Hollywood loves more to do
than Pat itself on the back they love
giving themselves Awards it's strange
the accountants of America don't give
themselves Awards the janitors of
America don't give themselves Awards but
the Hollywood people have multiple
Awards shows where they tell each other
how wonderful they are and then they
give long- winded speeches lecturing you
about how awful you are despite the fact
that you give them uh plenty of money so
that they can all become
multi-millionaires and uh make you know
quite good livings off of your cash uh
Jim Gaffigan was one of the people on
the Golden Globes the other day uh and
here's a quick 20 second clip I I
thought this joke was uh pretty pretty
pretty good Golden
Globes I mean
I I can't even believe I'm in the
entertainment
industry I can't I you know it's so
unlikely I'm from a small town in
Indiana I'm not a
pedophile you
know and they laughed they laughed and
you know the thing about comedy is
comedy is usually done best when you're
saying something true making people
laugh about it and then they have to
start thinking and obviously there's a
lot of problems uh in Hollywood in our
let's say political institutions this
Epstein list and a whole bunch more and
now I want to flash back and you'll see
how we're setting the show up today I
want to flash back to uh right before
the covid lockdowns of 2020 you might
think this is odd that it happened just
like two weeks before the covid
lockdowns this is the 2020 Golden Globes
and Ricky Jes was the host and he inin
generated Hollywood right to its face
hello and welcome to the 77th annual
Golden Globe Awards live from The
Beverly Hilton Hotel here in Los Angeles
I'm Ricky ja thank you um Kevin Hart was
fired from the Oscars because of some
offensive tweets
hello lucky for me the Hollywood Foreign
Press can barely speak English
and they've no idea what Twitter is so I
got offered this gig by fact
look talking of all you perverts it was
a big
year it was a big year for pedophile
movies um surviving R Kelly leaving
Neverland two popes shut up shut up I
don't care I don't
care many talented people of color were
snubbed in major categories um
unfortunately there's nothing we can do
about that the Hollywood Foreign Press
are all very very racist
so fifth time
so we were going to do an inmemoriam
this year but when I saw the list of
people that had died it wasn't diverse
enough it just
no it was mostly white people and I
thought nah not on my watch so spoiler
alert um season 2 is on the way so in
the end he obviously didn't kill himself
just like Jeffrey
Epstein shut up I know he's your friend
but I don't
care Apple roared into the the TV game
with a morning show a superb drama
yeah a superb drama about the importance
of dignity and doing the right thing
made by a company that runs sweat shops
in China so well you say you're woke but
the companies you work for I mean
unbelievable Apple Amazon Disney if Isis
started a streaming service you'd call
your agent wouldn't you so if you do win
an award tonight don't use it as a a
platform to make a political speech
right you're in no position to lecture
the public about anything you know
nothing about the real world most of you
spent less time in school than Greta
thumberg so if you win right come up
accept your little award thank your
agent and your God
and
so okay so the line that want to focus
on is right there at the end there's a
lot of good laughs in there and he's
doing some seriously dangerous stuff in
that room and again this was like two
weeks before lockdowns coincidence I
don't know who am I to say uh but the
line that I really like there you're in
no position to lecture the public
because we have been being lectured uh
by Hollywood Elite and actors and
politicians and all of these people for
a long time always telling us how racist
we are while they do all of the bad
stuff now interestingly that was in 2020
the Golden Globes did not air in 2022
because there was a Los Angeles time a
Los Angeles Times investigation that
detailed ethical collapses and a lack of
diversity within the ranks of the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association so
they didn't even have the Golden Globes
and an actual event they did bring it
back a couple days ago that was partly
what we showed you from the Jim Gaffigan
one uh but the purpose of all this is to
set up how far left and out of control
these people have gone and how much
damage they have done to our society as
a result of that we will do that in just
a moment but first I want to tell you
about Mo boox and I know that you guys
know that 60% of us pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet it's in your grocery aisle every day
well guys there's a better way and you
know that that's moink moo Plus on moink
delivers grass-fed and grass finish beef
and lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild Cod Alaskan salmon
straight to your door moink Farmers Farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moink meat tastes like it should
because the Family Farm Does It
Better the mo difference is a difference
you can taste and you can feel good
knowing you're helping Family Farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like ribe eyes to chicken breasts to
pork chops to Salmon plays and much more
plus you can cancel anytime Shark Tank
host Kevin oier called bacon the best
bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got moinked keep American
farming going by signing up at moink
box.com Ruben right now and listeners of
this show get free BR ground beef for a
year that's one of the best ground beef
you'll ever taste but for a limited time
M inkbox.com rubben moink box.com rubben
and now back to me so okay I want to I
want to say with where we started for
just a moment because uh we are in 2024
we have a bige ction coming the the the
rhetoric is being ratcheted up they're
telling you Hitler is coming back and
the white supremacists and all the stuff
and I want to just stay in that time
machine for a moment with a little bit
of a compilation of some of your
favorite Hollywood people uh talking
about yes orange man and the people who
support him enjoy I want my daughter to
grow up seeing a woman lead our
country and know that her possibilities
are
Limitless to Lady
[Music]
Gaga Bruce
Spring first and foremost and Katy Perry
if you are in a state and you're
watching throughout the US presidential
campaign Hillary Clinton had the Lion
Share of celebrity backing for Hillary
Clinton
tonight there's not going to be a
president Donald Trump
um that's not going to
happen uh it's not going to happen
because we're not going to be used fear
is not going to be something that we're
going to uh that's going to
be what drives our country we're not
going to be scared of Muslims or or or
immigrants or you know women we're not
actually afraid of anything so you know
we're not going to use fear so that's
not going to be an issue I had the
weirdest weirdest dream last night
remember that guy who used to host The
Apprentice
I dreamed we elected him
president the big story is that America
woke up this morning and was
like did I do
that if this morning you finally woke up
from a coma well you might want to go
back what we did was the Democratic
equivalent of installing an above ground
pool even if we're lucky and it doesn't
seep into our foundations the neighbors
will never look at at us the same way
again we put our 8-month-old son to bed
and I was holding him and I said to him
when you wake up tomorrow morning we
might have our first female president
and then when we came home around
midnight I uh went into his room shook
his crib until he woke up and scream we
have to get out of here now today
Americans have the right to feel happy
angry pessimistic optimistic but
everybody should feel grateful that we
get to vote and if we don't get our way
we have the chance to try again it is a
beautiful thing wow how about that Conan
O'Brien nailing it does he still have a
show whatever happened to that guy I
think he's in Ireland right now he
doesn't have a show anymore but he he
actually got the proper sentiment there
sometimes you win him sometimes you
don't but if you paint all of your
opponents as Nazis and Hitler you might
end up in a situation where we have
constant riots constant hysteria people
that are anxious all the time and think
that the world is about to end and
everything else the reason I again
wanted to do this time warp is because
all of these people they've sort of lost
control and they feel like they're
losing more and more control right
Hillary had the entire machine going for
her when Trump won the first time uh and
now the The Machine's ability to confuse
you I think is starting to whittle away
right because more people are tuning
into online shows they're not paying as
much attention to the mainstream media
unless people care about their opinions
real quick
one I didn't even think of when we did
our run through this morning George
Clooney who's not afraid of immigrants
and he's not afraid of Muslims or women
or anybody one time David and I were on
vacation in Cabo and we walked on the
beach public beach from the hotel and we
saw this beautiful house and we were
like oh let's go see that house we walk
over to the house and cops and security
and a whole bunch of people on on mopeds
and all stuff driving down the beach
grabbing us it was George Clooney's
house so he is for security for his own
house in on the beach but we probably
shouldn't have a Waller defend our
country anyway a little bit more with
these people because not only will they
tell you that uh you know Trump and his
supporters are Hitler and Nazis and the
rest of it they also like telling you
what they were going to do to Trump and
oddly they never ended up doing any of
this stuff gentlemen Robert
[Music]
[Applause]
Dao I'm going to say one thing
Trump as we act in the continuing
Narrative of stranger things we 1983
Midwestern will repel bullies we will
shelter Freaks and Outcast those who
have no home we will get past the lies
we will hunt monsters and when we are at
a loss amidst the hypocrisy and the
Casual violence of certain individuals
and institutions we will as per Chief
Jim Hopper punch some people in the face
when they seek to destroy the meat and
the disin FR and the marginalized and we
will do it all with soul with heart and
with joy we thank you for this response
yeah I mean you won't do any of that
stuff right F Trump we're going to punch
him in the face they're all applauding
each other they love each other so much
but it continues you may remember this
one from Merill Street an actor's only
job is to enter the lives of people who
are different from us and let you feel
what that feels like and there were many
many many powerful performances this
year that did exactly that breathtaking
compassionate work but there was one
performance this year that stunned me it
it sank its hooks in my heart not
because it was good it was there was
nothing good about it it was that moment
when the person asking to sit in the
most respected seat in our our country
imitated a disabled reporter someone he
outranked in privilege power and the
capacity to fight back and this instinct
to
humiliate when it's modeled by someone
in the public platform by someone
powerful it filters down into
everybody's life because it kind of
gives permission for other people to do
the same
thing dis disr invites disrespect
violence incites
violence when the powerful use their
position to bully others we all lose we
need the principled press to hold power
to account to to call them on the carpet
for every outrage it doesn't even matter
what Trump did or didn't do or did he
impersonate that guy or was in poor
taste or anything else the fact that
these people are so up their butts that
they're actually coming out of their
mouths is is the point that they have
lectured us and hemmed and haed all of
us while they have had everything right
and they think they can keep everything
by keeping the rest of us guilty let's
just do a bit more of this here's Walkin
Phoenix after he won the Oscar for me I
see
commonality I think whether we're
talking about gender inequality or
racism or queer rights or indigenous
rights or animal rights we're talking
about the fight against Injustice we're
talking about the fight against the
belief that one nation one people one
race one gender or one species has the
right to dominate control and use and
exploit another with
impunity
um I think that we've become very
disconnected from the natural world and
many of us what we're guilty of is an
egocentric worldview the belief that
we're the center of the universe we go
into the natural world and we plunder it
for its
resources we feel
entitled to artificially inseminate a
cow and when she gives birth we steal
her
baby even though her cries of Anguish
are
unmistakable and then we take her milk
that's intended for her calf and we put
it in our coffee and our cereal
okay I mean have I hit the point home
about the self-righteous nature of these
people you're an actor congratulations
you were Joker you were pretty good man
but what I'm going to go inseminate a
cow today just for the hell of it I
don't even know what the point of that
was wait is it not me that does it or
I'm gonna pay someone to do it I
guess and I'm gonna screw you Phoenix
walking Phoenix not this Phoenix anyway
just a a tiny bit more I promise you and
it's all coming home you may have seen
last week at the big New Year's Eve
spectacular Green Day and Green Day used
to be kind of cool I guess 30 years ago
when I was in college smoking pot and
fighting the power uh but they've
changed their words on some of their
songs and well you might have remember
this one from last
[Music]
week that's their number one song am
idiot and I'm not part of the Maga
agenda they're really fighting the power
somebody pointed out if you look at
these guys now look at these they look
like 50-year-old lesbians like what
happened they used to be fighting the
power they look like they were about to
drive a Tru a U-Haul over to Home Depot
to pick up some sod and uh build a
lesbian Fort or something okay there is
hope though that is the point that is
why I just bludgeoned you with all those
self-righteous Rich awful human beings
because there is hope people are not
buying in it anymore and I'm about to
prove it to you but let me tell you
about the satellite phone store and then
we'll get to it guys are you in the need
of a satellite phone yes you are well
sat1 123.com has made it easy for anyone
to get one sat phones are a secure way
to communicate with no tracking and no
one can listen to your calls or read
your texts the inmas smart elsat iPhone
elsat satellite phone is free on a
15-month agreement limited time only an
extra free batteries also included
$95.95 per month no cost for the phone
100 minutes of uh or text are also
included family plan multi free phones
are also available an extra free battery
for each phone is also included these
phones will work for from anywhere on
Earth cell phones only work from about
7% of the earth if you can see the sky
you'll be able to make a call if the
cellular networks go down you'll still
be able to stay in communication with
loved ones but satellite phones will
always work all satellite phone
Communications are encrypted ensure
privacy by using proprietary satellite
networks entrusted by the US government
for decades the US Senate recently
issued a SAT satellite phone for private
calls and security satellite phones
can't be tracked big Tech can't access
your data this year in the US we
experienced Maui cell service going down
to 90% of the island 60,000 people stuck
in the desert where only people with sat
phones were able to communicate
hurricanes that took self-service down
re be prepared go to sat1 123.com and
get your family ready that's sat1
123.com and now back to me
okay I put you through all of that how
long we've been doing this that was 17
minutes of lecturing by Hollywood filth
so now let's clean it up my man Jordan
Peterson was on pier Morgan show last
night and they talked about the Golden
Globes from a few days ago and how
there's been a shift away from all that
political yammering that we just showed
you I watched the Golden Globes last
night for example uh an event that was
taken off air last year in a row about
uh racial bias and so on in the
institution that puts it on uh and it
came back on really fascinating to me I
watched the whole thing for three hours
no political speeches no virtue
signaling no Grand standing people
basically did what Ricky Jes told them
to do three years ago which is get up
you know thank your agent and and sit
down and just celebrate making movies or
TV shows um is this a sign Jordan do you
think I I felt that there is a movement
going on now of a real backlash from
perhaps a majority that's been silent
till now has just said enough and that
even Hollywood has woken up to the
reality that people who watch the movies
and TV show they don't want to hear this
stuff all the
time well we put politics first and
foremost and partly the reason we did
that was because any higher AIMS in some
ways collapsed I suppose that's part and
parcel of the famous death of God if
what's highest spirit virally and
transcendentally disappears then
something else steps up to take its
place and in our society that's either
been a nihilistic bent that's very
powerful or politicking in general the
mistake that entertainers make is that
they regard what they do as mere
entertainment Hollywood stars and all
the people who were involved in
producing the narratives that entice and
and and uh compel us they're serving a
master whose High far higher than
anything merely political and when they
bend their art to serve a political
Master they distort the higher to the
lower to their own detriment the art
should never be subordinated to serve
the political because then it gets not
only does it get propagandistic it gets
dull and
contemptible no one cares what a star
thinks about Trump especially when what
they what they have to say about Trump
can be said just as coherently by your
demented
neighbor yes that is true and as your
demented neighbor I'm going to continue
for a moment so Jordan's point is that
art should be made for Art's Sake a
beautiful painting should be beautiful
because of what it brings out in you
that that that that actually is divine
and important but once that becomes
subservient to a political agenda you
get these hysterical people that that
are so incredibly self-righteous that
they think because they can pretend to
be an astronaut in a movie they can also
also tell you how to live your life but
the beauty the beauty is they are losing
control we know that these award shows
they Purge numbers every single year
right people are paying less attention
to the Golden Globes to the Oscars to
the emms all of these things we know
that Hollywood box office numbers are
completely tanking now that kind of
sucks to some degree because it used to
be cool to go to the movies and now we
do everything at home but that's a
separate issue for a moment but as they
have lost control what actually has
happened is that art for art sake has
started to come back now we'll go to
Ricky jves from his new Netflix special
which is out right now now I think it's
the number two thing on Netflix second
only to Dave Chappelle's new uh standup
special and here's Ricky jves making
some Politically Incorrect jokes telling
the truth for truth's sake and being
funny at the same time what a novel
approach well I am woke now I can prove
it there you go I love illegal
immigrants yeah suei now I sometimes I
go down to DOA for the day right and I I
look out right I look look for a boat
and I see a dinghy with about 60 of them
and I go over here like right and I pull
them in I pull them in to Shore and I go
Women and Children First they go there
are no women and children just you Lads
is it just come on
Lads if I go down there one day and
there's no boat I am absolutely gutted I
don't I just sort of wander into town
and I stand by the traffic lights and I
wait for a big Lory to pull up right and
I look underneath and there's a lad sort
of clutching like that and I go where
you headed he goes Gary Lin's house I go
it's just down
there for those of you not of the
British persuasion Gary liner is a
former football player who became an
analyst and then he was sort of into the
whole illegal immigration thing anyway
it doesn't matter the point is Ricky der
probably or Netflix in and of itself
would not have aired that sort of thing
five years ago that's the exact type of
thing that 5 years ago would have been
cancelled on Netflix if it had even made
it to Netflix in the first place but
what is happening in the world right now
well thanks to the Internet thanks to
online news shows where we're able to
share the truth to you enough people are
waking up not only to the BS from the
Hollywood Elite and their constant
lecturing and Haring of you but to the
reality on the ground so what is Ricky J
talking about there he's talking about
illegal immigration and it is a problem
whether you are in England or whether
you are in the United States so what's
happening in the United States right now
well I've got a video right here that
you're probably not going to see on CNN
today but you're going to see on a whole
bunch of the online news shows here's
what's going on on our Southern border
right now this is wild look at these
people and they are coming into our
country completely unfettered God only
knows what they believe and what they
stand on do and take a
look I actually want to go back to the
video because it's so it's so important
to see this we are told that these are
supposed to be the tired the poor the
huddled masses where are the women these
are look at this these are all men of
seemingly fighting age look at them
they're all well-dressed does anyone
there looks starving or destitute or
anything else do we have any idea what
any of their beliefs are when you put
that to the backdrop of what happened in
Israel on October 7th you wonder who
these people are that are coming to our
country how they're coming here who's
sending them here what their intentions
are people are waking up to this
nonsense and we better wake up well it
might be too late quite honestly because
they might at least for certain cities
and states because they've let so many
of these people in um we I suppose we'll
find out but speaking of one of the
cities and state that has let a whole
bunch of people in it is now suffering
the consequences of that New York state
is a sanctuary state New York City is a
sanctuary City uh there is a massive
Migrant Center in New York City where
they give them benefits and a whole
bunch of stuff uh someone cut a line uh
in uh going into the Asylum Center there
about 400 of them there here was a
little brawl a couple injured police
officers
enjoy that looks like the Lower East
Side of New York City like that used to
be a cool funky area to be in and it's
just like you don't know who's on the
streets anymore you don't know why
they're there they're getting services
that taxpaying New York City people do
not get they're then on the streets
drugs crime okay you get it now why is
the woke dying it's partly because we're
exposing this nonsense but it's also
because their ideas are so bad they are
so thin and occasionally they actually
tell us how bad and thin their ideas are
so now I want to go to AOC we haven't
played a clip of AOC in 2024 yet have we
AOC the wizard of of the Hamas caucus uh
she went on The Daily Show and
apparently The Daily Show does still
exist it's been very confusing to me
whether it exists at all anymore I'm not
even sure who the host is doesn't even
matter uh but here they are talking
about what we should do about illegal
immigration and listen to how well she
doesn't call it illegal immigration of
course but listen to how she says the
quiet part out loud from all parts of
the political Spectrum one of the
biggest issues that we have when it
comes to immigration is the fact that we
have undocumented population now you can
fix that by trying to build a wall or
you can fix that by trying to document
people and create a path to
citizenship and
um we'll have folks that might say look
at these systems you know that our
shelter system has weight and things
like that but one of the reasons that
our public systems experience weight is
because people don't have a documented
and reliable path to work and sustain
themselves just like all of our
ancestors did and our and our
grandparents our ancestors and our
grandparents came here legally I am
guessing if you watch this for the most
part your ancestors came here legally my
great grandparents on both sides what
was it for your family if you don't know
think about it do a little research ask
your parents ask your grandparents look
at a family tree uh the idea that oh
they're undocumented so the solution is
just document them oh there's 12 million
of them here we don't know how many are
pouring through the Border just document
them send them in give them some dos and
that'll solve the problem that doesn't
solve any of the problems that probably
makes the problem worse in in some
extent to to just say oh yes as many
people as you want come here as long as
we document you you're good to go uh but
there was something oddly refreshing
about that clip where she flat out says
it what their plan is it's not about a
wall it's not about a border it's just
about bringing in as many of these
people as possible and again you only
you need only go to the video we showed
you right before that to to go like is
it racist to be like who are these
people what are their intentions where
are all the chicks where are all the
kids where's where's the old woman I
mean picture of picture Ellis Island
1937 the old woman right the 80-year-old
woman with the with the bag holding like
a you know one apple or something trying
to get in with the schmata on her head
trying to get into this country
compare it to that you think there's a
problem but it is nice to see them
double down and then of course what do
they do they always they double down on
their bad policies their bad policies no
wall document these people and then of
course they blame Republicans so uh as
you guys know it is one of the few jobs
of the president of the United States to
defend the Border that's part of what
the federal government is supposed to do
the Democrats are not doing that it's
intentional I have no doubt that it is
intentional uh and then places like New
York which have become Sanctuary cities
start getting pissed because uh other
places that don't want all these
illegals like Texas which of course is a
border state with Mexico uh Governor
abbit up in over down in Texas he has
been sending people via bus to New York
City and Eric Adams is not happy about
it as we show you this video of Eric
Adams I just I have this feeling that
he's actually a robot from here down
that it's a robotic body and they've
just put a head on him that's a sidebar
to all this but it's worth noting have
you been outsmarted by the Texas
governor GRE gbot uh no anyone who has a
diabolical mind would do diabolical
things to just treat people in in
inhumane way we handled over 164,000
migrants and Asylum Seekers and we're
doing it in a humane way we're very
clear that we're going to continue to
adjust as the governor of Texas carry
out these actions to make sure that we
sent a very clear loud message no bus
company should be participating in this
action and we're going to to communicate
with our partners in this region and
make sure that we tell them they should
file the same level of executive order
to stop this from taking place okay this
is rather extraordinary and this is what
they do with everything so again it's
his party it's the Democrats that are
allowing everybody in Greg Abbott is a
republican he's saying hey we don't want
these people in Texas you Eric Adams
you're a sanctuary city mayor you've got
all these resources apparently and
you're not diabolical I'm Greg Abbot I'm
diabolical I'm a Republican I'm racist
duh I'm white take them why don't you
want them anymore and by the way it is
not Humane to take these people and then
give them these crumbs that you give
them because it's not Humane to the good
taxpaying people who live in New York
City if there's any decent people in New
York City left my mother-in-law lives
there for some God godforsaken reason
I'm trying to get her down here to
Florida but you are not being Humane to
the people who are actually the
functioning people in the system but
anyway these bus companies are
going over to New York dropping people
off and Eric Adams instead of suing the
federal government or making Joe Biden
do his job he's mostly pissed at the bus
companies New York City has and will
continue to do our part to manage this
humanitarian crisis but we cannot bear
the course of Reckless political PLO
from the state of Texas alone today our
Administration filed a lawsuit against
17 companies that have taken part in
Texas governor Greg Abbott's scheme to
transport tens of thousands of migrants
to New York City in an attempt to
overwhelm our Social Services System
these companies have violated state law
by not paying the cost of caring for
these migrants and that's why we are
suing to recoup approximately $700
million already spent to care for
migrants bust here in the last two years
by the state of Texas governor Abbott's
continuing use of migrants as political
pwns is not only chaotic and inhumane
but makes clear he puts politics over
people today's lawsuit should serve as a
warning to all those who break the law
in this way Joe Biden is breaking the
law by allowing these people in you are
Mr humanitarian offering these people
services in your Sanctuary City buddy I
don't think you can sue a bus company
it's not the bus company's
responsibility to take care of my what
do you the bus company puts people on a
you're not going to believe this a bus
company transports people to different
places on a bus you get on a Greyhound
bus you start in hackin sack New Jersey
you end up in where do you want to
go Boise Idaho that's what they do over
at bus companies the bus company is not
responsible for your life when you get
off that bus but it's not just him
these people these
unqualified brainless buffoons who have
been elected by the Democrats you all
deserve observe each other so here's
another guy here's Chicago mayor Brandon
Johnson and this is the guy who rep
replaced Lori Lightfoot uh he's also
because he's a sanctuary City guy
because he's Humane and compassionate
until push comes to shove and then
suddenly starts freaking out uh he's
also very upset with Greg Abbott from
Texas because they're getting more brown
people in Chicago and I thought brown
people were the best people but
apparently not if there's too many of
them you and other Democratic Mayors I
might add many black May is is uh has
been the focal of this in fact on
Thursday New York city mayor Eric Adams
F uh uh filed a $700 million lawsuit
against 17 charter bus companies who
transported migrants from Texas what are
your thoughts about the case and is this
an action you would consider taken as
well well you know look you're very
you're absolutely right about the
intentions of governor Abit he is
attacking democratically ran cities and
particularly cities that are being led
um by black leaders or leaders of color
this is unconscionable it's a very
raggedy approach and quite frankly not
only is it Reckless and Raggedy um but
it is evil spirited I honestly cannot
believe these are real people it's evil
spirited it's diabolical again the
Diabolical thing is not defending our
border the Diabolical uh card to be
handed out here if that falls on
anyone's doorstep Joe Biden and the
Democrats doorstep it's you idiots who
who give lip service all the time and
say oh we're Sanctuary cities cuz we're
good guys until push comes to shove when
you're suddenly freaking out I also love
how they frame this that there's somehow
what Greg Abbott is doing he's putting
this all on these black Mayors right
because Greg Abbott must be a racist so
he's sending it to the black mayor in
New York City who was a sanctuary city
mayor the black mayor of Chicago who was
a sanctuary city mayor it's just
ridiculous by the way you know I said
that uh Eric he seems like a robot
underneath he seems like he keep his
body keeps getting bigger head stays the
same uh Al Sharpton his head stays the
same and his body is getting smaller
there's some I I don't know what that is
we're going to work on that do a little
research figure out what it is anyway
another clown in this circus is
Department of Homeland Security
secretary Alejandro mayores uh who also
is not happy with Greg Abbott now it's
his job he works for Joe Biden it's his
job to protect the Border he's upset
that Greg Abbott's doing something about
it let me let me identify one
fundamental problem here and that is the
fact that we have one
governor in the state of Texas who is
refusing to cooperate with other other
Governors and other local officials and
coordinate efforts to address a
challenge that our country which this
country should Stand United to address
that our country is facing and it's a
remarkable failure of governance to
refuse to cooperate with one's fellow
local and state officials extraordinary
everything he just said right there he
should be saying about himself it's his
job to protect the Border this isn't
Greg Abbott's fault Greg Abbott's trying
to do something as the chief executive
of his State he's seeing his State be
overrun he's putting people in buses
saying sorry you don't have to go home
but you can't stay here go suck it up
live in Chicago which is most likely far
more dangerous actually for the
immigrants than wherever they uh came
from but may every may orcus just said
there was an unbelievable lie it's on
him it's on him he should be impeached
Biden should go down like a sane country
these people should all be gone this is
far worse than anything Donald Trump
ever did or January 6 or anything else
they are literally leading an invasion
into our country but now let's connect
this to the top of the show because we
were talking about the Hollywood Elite
the Hollywood Elite who will gladly
lecture you and be very upset when the
migrants show up in their Sanctuary
cities and be very really when they're
really upset though it's when they show
up to their vacation spots like Martha's
Vineyard um and they will tell you how
horrible you are while they of course
make uh plenty of money in the process
we have not shown a clip have we shown a
clip in the New Year from The View I
think this is our first view clip of the
year here's once sane actress whoopy
Goldberg telling you how horrible you
are and Republicans are mean and a bunch
more I'm sorry what's interesting for me
is
that
people's faith in the country is waning
that's the that's the thing that's
pissing me off because in fact there's a
reason Joe Biden ran the way he did
there's a reason he's running for
democracy now because that's really
what's at stake you worried that you
can't pay your bill wait till he the
other guy becomes president and you
won't have to worry about it cuz you'll
be in some Camp somewhere cuz that's his
promise his promise to us is he's going
to force people to do his bidding that's
what he said I'm this I'm going to be
good on day one and I'm going to turn
into this other person so here's the
deal this is all up to you this is all
up to you we're going sit up here till
we're Green in the face but this really
comes down to the people what is the
country you want do you want the country
that you kind of thought you had where
we all get to say what we think and we
don't have to be afraid of being
American believing that yeah there will
be people who come in and some will get
in quick and some will take a different
route but they're coming here for a
reason cuz they're living in a place
that's not good for their families if
you're okay with that you understand
that then fight for us to find a better
way to make immigration work fight for
that don't fight for keeping everybody
out because then we all have to leave
whoopies worth a cool 60 mil I wonder
how much of that maybe we can send an
email to her Representatives how much
she'll be putting towards building
housing for these people maybe she could
let a couple people in her house that
would be real nice of uh of whoopy to do
right there um of course everything
she's saying again it's the reverse of
the truth right she's saying that the
Republicans will crash the economy the
economy was actually doing unbelievably
well under Trump before covid right Co
obviously changed the game on that and
we that's a kind of separate issue altoe
again this thing about we're nice so we
want people to come in to the country
they're nice so they don't so what
they're doing in essence is they're not
only blaming Republicans for the Border
even though Republicans are not in
charge of the border of the country
right now but they're also they're also
blaming you for being concerned with
what you see right in front of you right
so it's like Republicans are really mean
and look what they do and that guy from
Texas the white guy sends it to the
black mayor in Chicago and and then also
if you notice that oh it is a little odd
that thousands of 25-year-old men who
look perfectly healthy and wellfed are
streaming into our country you're
somehow a racist and it's also you the
bad guy uh speaking of bad guys another
one from The View Sunny host who again
she's the worst she's the worst of the
worst of the worst uh here she is
explaining how it's again the
Republicans fault that everything bad is
happening in this country because the
Republicans are making people dumb what
we're seeing by the Republican party and
I give it to them we're seeing a long
game we're seeing that they are
dismantling or attempting to
dismantle institutions all of a sudden
the most elite colleges in and
universities in the world which by the
way they all went to everybody in the
Supreme Court went there Elise stonic
went there all the Congress people went
there te Cruz went there those schools
are not good enough anymore because I
think because now people that don't look
like them we're getting in affirmative
action no more why so that people that
don't look like them don't get in women
don't have Reproductive Rights anymore
over their own bodies why so they can
have power over women why are why is
French and Mandarin and Spanish being
taken away from our Public Schools so
that we can be a monistic a mon a
monolingual society and can't compete
globally we the Republicans are
intentionally dumbing down our
electorate erasing history so that past
can become prologue and so they can
remain in power and it's grievance
politics at its best and it's because
people see what Sarah was saying I can't
pay my electric bill my my gas Bill's
High I I need my food and why is that
why is my station in life like this it's
because that black guy got into Harvard
and became president or it's because
that immigrant is over there doing
better than not driving a nicer car than
I'm driving it's grievance politics but
culture wars specific she she's she's
actually evil like I don't know how
often I call someone like outright evil
on the show but her level of dishonesty
there and again it's just you need only
look at a mirror everything she accused
the rest of us of is exactly what she's
guilty of it's the Republicans taking
out the institutions the slow March the
institutions it's you guys who allowed
all of the marxists and the Communists
into the institutions that has led to
all of this it's you guys who have
opened up the border so then a bunch of
people start seeing what's happening you
it's you guys who have destroyed the
economy with economics right and the
endless printing of money so that Goods
cost more and things of that nature it's
you guys who did everything that you're
accusing the rest of us of doing but
again the theme of the show is that more
and more people are waking up to this
right and the idea that somehow it's the
Republican that the Republicans want
their people to be dumb right it's it's
the Democrats who by destroying
education have basically created two
generations now of seriously stupid
people because they need their stupid
people kind of stupid and genderless and
confused about Race and History and
everything else so that they can have
all of their authoritarian Tendencies
put into policy so while they instill
all of these ridiculous woke policies
enough of us are starting to reject it
and that is causing a problem now they
could be like you know maybe we should
think about this and maybe we should do
a little something about the Border
maybe there's some ways but no they
always double down blame you and then
they kind of tell you what they're
coming up with next so this one check
this one out uh Michelle Obama I knew
she was the first lady some people think
she's a dude I'm sort of agnostic on
that um but anyway she was married she's
married to Barack Obama she's making the
rounds on the podcasts again and you
know clearly they're looking for a
replacement for Joe and maybe they're
testing that thing out I think they
tested it out with Gavin Newsome for a
while that's that kind of Crash and
burned which is spectacular uh but she
went on this podcast uh to talk about
what she's worried about and listen to
this get a mirror lady what's going to
happen in this next election I am
terrified about what could possibly
happen because our leaders matter who we
select who speaks for us who holds that
bullied Pulpit it affects us in ways
that sometimes I think people take for
granted you know the fact that people
think that government ah you know is is
it does it really even do anything and
I'm like oh my God does government do
everything for us and we cannot take
this democracy for granted and sometimes
I I worry that we do those are the
things that keep me up oh really lady
government does everything for
us I think you all know that I've always
felt the nine most terrifying words in
the English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to help I mean
do you see the Stark difference in these
people that's about 40 years ago Ronald
Reagan right the government is the
problem the ever encroaching power that
that thing above you has over every
decision of your life and how it has
infected your child's brains and
everything else that is the problem the
government does everything for us well
the government's done an awful lot for
you Michelle Obama because you're worth
like a cool 50 mil after your husband
was a was a meager what was he it was a
social organizer what do they call him a
community organizer and a mild mannered
Senator and somehow now he's worth about
50 mil and he's got that house right on
the water over there in Martha's
Vineyard 30 Acres over there why he
bought a house that poor schmuck why he
bought a house on the water with global
warming I feel bad for him um but yes
the government is the bad guys but they
they want you to believe that the
government are the good guys and to
flash back to what Jordan was talking
about once you remove God from the
equation you remove something that is
good and eternal and always above all of
us you remove that you end up killing
art and then you end up also killing the
basic ways that we can function as a
society because people want to replicate
it they want to replace something above
us with something and then it will come
in the form of an authoritarian
government so now we will wrap this all
up going back to Jordan Peterson talking
to Piers Morgan and why you must dare I
say think for yourself did a guy write a
book a couple years ago about thinking
for yourself in an age of unreason that
was a pretty good book
as we get better at doing good things
faster we simultaneously get better at
doing bad things faster and at a wider
scale and you know I concluded decades
ago and this is partly why I stayed as a
psychologist rather than say pursuing a
political career is that we've always
known in the west that the weight of the
world rests on our individual shoulders
right the central story of the West is
that each person is to take up their
cross and carry it uphill and that
that's a Divine calling and that the
fate of the world in some sense depends
on that and we're going to see Pierce in
the next 30 Years we're going to see and
it might be a lot faster than that just
exactly how true that is as the evidence
for the world disrupting consequences of
our hypothetically trivial errors start
to become increasingly manifest
increasingly and rapidly manifest lay
lay out the underlying archetypal
structure of reality in the endless
battle between good and evil and the
most profound commentators on such
battle have always concluded that the
fundamental line is drawn in the human
soul and if you want to get the Demons
of the world under control you better
start with the demons in your own skull
and if you don't think that's enough to
keep you busy that just means you
haven't looked inside with enough what
courage and perspicacity there's plenty
of disorder in your own soul to occupy
yourself with for the rest of your life
and this is something uh we're either
going to learn this
voluntarily consciously and wisely or
we're going to be Beat to Death by our
own stupidity and that's going to happen
quickly in many many ways you can see it
unfolding do you see how Stark and
obvious the choice is what do you think
is right what do you think is right and
true that it is your job as a human
being to bear that cross figure out your
fight for what is right and true
through and take the slings and arrows
for all of that and maybe build a better
Society along the way but do it first
for yourself and your family and your
local community and go that way or do
you think what Michelle Obama said is
right what would we do without the
government the government's really in it
for us that is the easy answer and it is
and it is the wrong answer Hollywood is
not going to solve your problems the
government is not going to solve your
problems you can solve your problems and
then maybe through that that exist itial
struggle like maybe that's how we
correct things maybe that's that's the
best one I've come up with if you've got
a better one I'd like to hear it that's
why we do postgame shows coming up in 30
seconds Ruben report. locals.com
reminder guys we have a new Twitter
account at Ruben report show if you want
to get clips of the show that are easily
sharable uh and since we did a bunch
with Eric Adams today we leave you with
a little more Eric Adams and we will see
you tomorrow you can look in a jewelry
box a jewelry box of this nature maybe a
simple jewelry box but if you look
through it closely you don't know what
your child may be hiding for instance a
gun look at picture frames and behind
them cameras try to determine what's
what's taking place behind a picture
frame you can find bullets you should
always when your child bring in his
popular napsack with many different
locations look through it to see what
exactly is your child carrying in
addition to a book something simple as a
crack pipe something simple as a as a
baby doll could be just a baby doll but
also it could be a place where you can
secrete or hide drugs run your hands
over the pillows and see if you feel
anything that's unusual like a pillow
like this with the button is a perfect
invitation to hide something and I've
felt something bumpy I will reach in see
what it is just look and see what's
inside your bookcases it could be more
than just books perfect place to hide uh
cocaine
[Music]